Detective Inspector Oscar milks [ __ ]  just ask you a few questions  did you know miss Cavell read with  neighbors she was always kind to me so  you didn't hear anything no 28 year old  Veronique radish fell from her apartment  building and what appears to be a  suicide alleged war criminal officially  identified his daughter's body did you  know they'd only kill Sofia please look  after it for me it was a woman in the  end of my arm she's blind  [Music]  is it true that the loss of one sense  sharpens the others I'm being followed  these people kill everyday  [Applause]  whatever game you think you're playing  you just stumbled into someone else's  you don't have to do this  you  you